In this chapter our goal is to introduce some
metrics for measuring the performance of a
circuit and then investigate ways to improve
that performance.
We'll start by putting aside circuits for
a moment and look at an everyday example that
will help us understand the proposed performance
metrics.
Laundry is a processing task we all have to
face at some point!
The input to our laundry "system" is some
number of loads of dirty laundry and the output
is the same loads, but washed, dried, and
folded.
There two system components: a washer that
washes a load of laundry in 30 minutes, and
a dryer that dries a load in 60 minutes.
You may be used to laundry system components
with different propagation delays, but let's
go with these delays for our example.
Our laundry follows a simple path through
the system:
each load is first washed in the washer and
afterwards moved to the dryer for drying.
There can, of course, be delays between the
steps of loading the washer, or moving wet,
washed loads to the dryer, or in taking dried
loads out of the dryer.
Let's assume we move the laundry through the
system as fast as possible, moving loads to
the next processing step as soon as we can.
Most of us wait to do laundry until we've
accumulated several loads.
That turns out to be a good strategy!
Let's see why…
To process a single load of laundry, we first
run it through the washer, which takes 30
minutes.
Then we run it through the dryer, which takes
60 minutes.
So the total amount of time from system input
to system output is 90 minutes.
If this were a combinational logic circuit,
we'd say the circuit's propagation delay is
90 minutes from valid inputs to valid outputs.
Okay, that's the performance analysis for
a single load of laundry.
Now let's think about doing N loads of laundry.
Here at MIT we like to make gentle fun of
our colleagues at the prestigious institution
just up the river from us.
So here's how we imagine they do N loads of
laundry at Harvard.
They follow the combinational recipe of supplying
new system inputs after the system generates
the correct output from the previous set of
inputs.
So in step 1 the first load is washed and
in step 2, the first load is dried, taking
a total of 90 minutes.
Once those steps complete, Harvard students
move on to step 3, starting the processing
of the second load of laundry.
And so on…
The total time for the system to process N
laundry loads is just N times the time it
takes to process a single load.
So the total time is N*90 minutes.
Of course, we're being silly here!
Harvard students don't actually do laundry.
Mummy sends the family butler over on Wednesday
mornings to collect the dirty loads and return
them starched and pressed in time for afternoon
tea.
But I hope you're seeing the analogy we're
making between the Harvard approach to laundry
and combinational circuits.
We can all see that the washer is sitting
idle while the dryer is running and that inefficiency
has a cost in terms of the rate at which N
load of laundry can move through the system.
As engineering students here in 6.004, we
see that it makes sense to overlap washing
and drying.
So in step 1 we wash the first load.
And in step 2, we dry the first load as before,
but, in addition, we start washing the second
load of laundry.
We have to allocate 60 minutes for step 2
in order to give the dryer time to finish.
There's a slight inefficiency in that the
washer finishes its work early, but with only
one dryer, it's the dryer that determines
how quickly laundry moves through the system.
Systems that overlap the processing of a sequence
of inputs are called pipelined systems and
each of the processing steps is called a stage
of the pipeline.
The rate at which inputs move through the
pipeline is determined by the slowest pipeline
stage.
Our laundry system is a 2-stage pipeline with
a 60-minute processing time for each stage.
We repeat the overlapped wash/dry step until
all N loads of laundry have been processed.
We're starting a new washer load every 60
minutes and getting a new load of dried laundry
from the dryer every 60 minutes.
In other words, the effective processing rate
of our overlapped laundry system is one load
every 60 minutes.
So once the process is underway N loads of
laundry takes N*60 minutes.
And a particular load of laundry, which requires
two stages of processing time, takes 120 minutes.
The timing for the first load of laundry is
a little different since the timing of Step
1 can be shorter with no dryer to wait for.
But in the performance analysis of pipelined
systems, we're interested in the steady state
where we're assuming that we have an infinite
supply of inputs.
We see that there are two interesting performance
metrics.
The first is the latency of the system, the
time it takes for the system to process a
particular input.
In the Harvard laundry system, it takes 90
minutes to wash and dry a load.
In the 6.004 laundry, it takes 120 minutes
to wash and dry a load, assuming that it's
not the first load.
The second performance measure is throughput,
the rate at which the system produces outputs.
In many systems, we get one set of outputs
for each set of inputs, and in such systems,
the throughput also tells us the rate at inputs
are consumed.
In the Harvard laundry system, the throughput
is 1 load of laundry every 90 minutes.
In the 6.004 laundry, the throughput is 1
load of laundry every 60 minutes.
The Harvard laundry has lower latency, the
6.004 laundry has better throughput.
Which is the better system?
That depends on your goals!
If you need to wash 100 loads of laundry,
you'd prefer to use the system with higher
throughput.
If, on the other hand, you want clean underwear
for your date in 90 minutes, you're much more
concerned about the latency.
The laundry example also illustrates a common
tradeoff between latency and throughput.
If we increase throughput by using pipelined
processing, the latency usually increases
since all pipeline stages must operate in
lock-step and the rate of processing is thus
determined by the slowest stage.